écrivain juriste politiciens homme aux
multiples facettes léon blum personnages
importants de l'histoire de france 9
avril 2022 date du 150e anniversaire de
sa naissance et pour l'occasion une
conférence débat était animé par un
enseignant doctorant en philosophie
politique à la salle du vieux marché a
joué en josas de rappeler à cette
occasion à l'ensemble de sa vie mais
aussi d'essayer de sans trop forcer voir
la manière dont sept dans cette ville où
les différentes expériences de cette vie
peuvent résonner jusqu'à aujourd'hui à
la fois dans nous dans nos vies
personnelles et puis surtout dans notre
expérience politique collective le thème
de cette soirée léon blum quel héritage
aujourd'hui un aspect mémorielle mais
aussi des problématiques qui font écho
dans notre société actuelle il symbolise
au plus haut point des valeurs
d'attachement la république et notamment
la valeur de justice qui à mon avis est
une valeur essentielle
et puis il avait aussi une conception de
la france de la nationalité de la
citoyenneté qui parle beaucoup à la
période d'aujourd'hui je suis convaincu
je le dis assez souvent bloom aurait
trouvé les mots par rapport à tout le
débat qu'est ce qu'un citoyen qu'est ce
que l'identité
une centaine de personnes étaient
présents dans la salle pour l'historien
pascal ory il y a deux raisons de
commémorer la mémoire de léon blum c'est
un très bel exemple d'homme politique et
franchement on peut penser
qu'aujourd'hui mais c'est pas nouveau
dans les années 30 aussi l'homme
politique la politique les partis
politiques ne sont pas toujours
considéré de façon très favorable et
c'est profondément injuste à toutes les
époques puis deuxièmement parce que les
solutions qu'il propose qu'on peut
qualifier de social démocrate sont
peut-être pas tellement au devant de la
scène mais à mon avis quand on considère
ce qui se passe dans d'autres pays je
pense que il ya une philosophie
politique dont il faut tenir compte
cette soirée était organisée par la
mairie de jouer en josas et
l'association de la maison léon blum qui
a pour mission de faire vivre sa mémoire
à travers différentes manifestations
culturelles et bien évidemment à travers
sa demeure la maison léon blum se trace
se trouve dans le quartier des mets a
joué en josas donc sur les hauteurs ici
nous sommes bien dans la dans la ville
où léon blum a vécu les cinq dernières
années de sa vie si on veut comprendre
léon blum la maison dit beaucoup de
choses
une petite maison assez modeste le
bureau y est énorme à l'intérieur du
bureau il ya une table travail qui est
énorme et puis derrière son immense
bibliothèque la soirée en l'honneur de
léon blum s'est terminée par des
dédicaces avec les auteurs internement